STEPHANIE WONG: In
the last episode,
we explained how
the GCP global load
balancer is able
to overflow traffic
to back in instance
scripts in the next closest
region during traffic spikes.
Not only is this more
reliable for Beyond Treats'
growing online business, but
it also gives dog parents
a better overall experience with
lower overall latency risks.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: But the
Beyond Treats leadership
is hesitant, and they
want to save cost
in as many places as possible.
They have a new claim to fame
after being featured on TV,
and are new to serving online
customers around the world.
Will global load balancing give
them a noticeable difference
in performance versus regional?
STEPHANIE WONG: Today, we're
going to find that out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What we'll be creating today
is a simple test web server
running a CPU-intensive
application
that computes Mandelbrot sets.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: What
are Mandelbrot sets?
STEPHANIE WONG: A
Mandelbrot set is
generated by computational
iteration, which
means to repeat a process
over and over again.
And that will be a Python script
we install on our load test
instances.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Huh.
OK.
I'm intrigued.
STEPHANIE WONG: We'll then
measure network capacity
using load testing tools
on one VM instance.
Next, we'll add a single
region load balancer
with back ends in
the same region,
and then measure
the response time.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And then
let me guess, after that, we
will test the
performance when we scale
the network to multiple regions
using global load balancing,
and then compare that
with the performance using
a single regional load balancer.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yes.
Ding, ding, ding!
Exactly.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Awesome.
I am super excited.
Let's do it.
Let's go through
the ingredients.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yes.
Here they are.
You'll need load testing
tools like siege and httperf.
Siege simulates requests from
a specified number of users,
so you can see the capacity
and expected response
times for an application.
httperf sends a specific
number of requests per second,
regardless of whether responses
or errors are received.
It tells you how
applications respond to load.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: You also need
a single [INAUDIBLE] machine
instance back end, a single
region load balancer,
and a single region
managed instance group.
And finally, a global load
balancer with multi-regional
managed instance groups.
STEPHANIE WONG: To start, create
a VPC network for testing,
then define a firewall rule
to allow internal traffic
and allow SSH
traffic to the VPC.
Now, lets determine
the serving capacity
of a single VM instance.
Create a VM called web
server with four CPUs.
Include a startup script that
installs the Mandelbrot server.
Create a firewall rule to
allow external access to it,
and then grab the VM
public IP address.
Enter it in your browser, and
you get the computed Mandelbrot
set.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Then create
a second VM in the same zone
called load test.
[? Text ?] ssh into
the load test instance
and install siege and httperf.
And try to request
around 20 requests
from four parallel users.
You should get an output of
about 5.05 requests per second.
Using httperf, run 500 requests
at the rate of four requests
per second, and repeat
it at different rates,
like 5, 7, and 10
requests per second.
You will see that
the system can handle
five requests per second,
and then drastically
jumps in response time
and connection errors
when you have 7 or 10
connections per second.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK, now let's
put a single region load
balancer in front with
the managed instance
group in the same region.
Once you create the
https load balancer
with three VMs in the same
region using a managed instance
template, and health checks,
you can run the same load test
against the load balance system.
As a load increases
past serving capacity,
the average and maximum request
latency increases sharply.
With 10 requests per second,
the average request latency
is close to 500 milliseconds.
But with 20 requests
per second, the latency
is 5,000 requests per second.
It's a tenfold increase.
Your dog fans are
not going to be happy
when you have a flash buy
one get one free sale on dog
birthday cakes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Now,
here's the real test.
Let's set up a global web
server with https load balancing
with back ends deployed
in multiple regions.
Once you create a
managed instance
group, in second region, with
a maximum capacity of 10 RPS,
run 500 requests at 10 RPS,
and you will get the results.
After the system stabilizes,
the average response time
is around 400
milliseconds, at 10 RPS,
and a minor increase to 700
milliseconds, at 20 RPS.
Seems like the
discrepancy is a lot less
than the 5,000
milliseconds delay
we saw with the
regional load balancer.
STEPHANIE WONG: In our
regional load balancer test,
we saw the load balancer
became overloaded when traffic
increased past capacity.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
This is what tends
to happen with typical
on-premise load balancers,
or when using the standard tier
network on regional https load
balancers.
STEPHANIE WONG: The
request latencies
increased by more than 10x.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Meanwhile,
using the global https load
balancing setup lets
your traffic overflow
to the next closest region with
available serving capacity.
You have lower increase
in end user latency,
and a better user
experience, meaning--
STEPHANIE WONG: Beyond
Treats' customers will still
be able to order pumpkin pie,
flax buscuits, peanut butter
treats, and carrot cakes
on National Dog Day.
No full service outages
when traffic spikes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
For more information
about GCP's global
load balancing
optimizing application latency,
check out the documentation
in the link below.
STEPHANIE WONG: That's all for
today on Get Cooking in Cloud.
Here's hoping you are whipping
up your own capacity management
with Cloud load balancers.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: If
you liked this video
and would like to see
more such content,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]